[Applause]
I love that we kind of go are colorful
yes how are you I'm so good I'm so happy
you're here in person I know the last
time it was over Zoom I know this whole
show I feel like the last time I saw
people was over zoom and it's it's fine
but it's like cooler in person so thank
you for making it yeah and thank you co
for allowing us to hang out
right I have to ask that we I I feel
like we have to have some similar
interest like vocally growing up like
musically like what were your influences
um Okay so so a lot of Fleet with Mac I
mean Stephen Nick I I like have the
Husky raspy Bon yes Bonnie R you can Bel
like you know that like big voice sound
right and growing up I just couldn't get
enough Fleet with Mac um and then come
on Seline Deion oh my God Whitney yeah
ARA amen so much ARA I remember my uh my
my aunt she would always play like Al
Green artha all the mtown my dad D was
like heart he loved he was obsessed with
anything that was classic rock so he
would act when we were kids he would put
this the radio on and he'd say all right
here's the deal this is like the best
way for a parent if they want to like
only listen to what they want to listen
to pay your children tell me pay your
children so this is what he would do he'
say here's the deal we're going to play
this game called the dollar game okay
now it was actually really helpful
looking back because it trained my ear
but he would say if you could guess
who's singing the song then I'll give
you a dollar if it's really hard I'll
give you $5 yeah he got to listen to
whatever he wanted meanwhile I'm I'm
making some cash right so I'm like I
want to know I want to know what what
song and it was training my ear and I
didn't come from a musical family like I
I know I just found so much
joy and
money and I got paid I would have loved
that meanwhile my mom was like can you
not sing so loud in the car like
probably cuz I was trying to I was
always trying I love the background part
when I was a kid like learning I was
like what's happening there I found that
so interesting did you start harmonies
when you were young yes I I well I don't
think I was good at it which is why my
mother wanted me to shut up but I I
think that's why I you know I put in the
work in the car every time we were in
the car we were always listening to the
radio she loves music nobody like really
saying in my family like to the extent
of like what we do but like I they love
music like everybody did but I want to
give you a pop quiz cuz your dad if he
trained you well I want give you
a
you got a pup quiz for
[Music]
Lauren
oh they yeah that's what song is
that wait hold up wait for
it come to Kelly you don't make look at
here Dad it's
$55 you get you get a bonus cuz you made
it so your tour has been going so well
you extended it that's incredible to
through 2024 right thank you do you love
being on the road I love it the it's
called the collidoscope tour and this is
what I love about being on the road tell
me if this is kind of your thing so
every single night I always tell people
I wish you could see from my vantage
point like yeah your perspective yeah my
perspective getting there and seeing
these faces some of them have tears
falling down their faces some of them
have so much joy and excitement some of
them are hugging their loved ones some
of them are are grieving and you can see
that just seeing the expression of
humanity as a whole it is like my
favorite thing everybody comes with
their different story their different
background and it's the it's the best to
me and then getting to sing and like
sing over people sing out from that
place you know I just I love it it's my
favorite thing my band it's the best
connection yeah yeah it is it's the
thing where music is that thing where
you can you don't even have to speak the
same language but you can enter a song
into the the atmosphere of the room or
whatever and everything can change you
can know someone in a second it's like
oh I've spent a lifetime with you but
it's just the way that something has a
sound has interacted with their Spirit
or their soul the same way that it's
interacting with yours and all of a
sudden there's this kismi thing right I
love I live and breathe and die for that
experience it is the best so and then
yeah when you have a band that you love
being with like I
can't I heard you've only been with him
like 20 years can't stand I love them um
we're going to see you perform Jingle
Bells later you filmed it you filmed it
at right yes yeah well we need a quick
break Lauren's two time Grammy nominated
album is called Lauren Bagel it's
incredible um but stick around y'all
because Lauren's got a special
performance for us later in the
[Music]
show
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home